And now...
'ASAP Science' offers:
The Element of the Periodic Table
There is Hydrogen and Helium
Dan Lithium, Berillium
Drill, Carbon everywhere
Nitrogen anywhere in the air
With Oxygen so you can breathe
And Fluor for your beautiful teeth
Neon to illuminate the signboards
Sodium for salty times
Magnesium, Aluminum, Silicone
Phosphorus, then Sweal, Chlorine and Argon
Potassium, and Calcium so you will grow strongly
Skandium, Titanium, Vanadium and Chromium and Manganese
This is the periodic table
Noble gases are stable
Halogens and alkali react aggressively
Every period will see a new outside shell
While electrons are being added, moving to the right
Iron in the 26th
Then Cobalt, you get nickel coins
Copper, Zinc and Gallium
Germanium and Arsenic
Selenium and Broom film
While Kripton helps to illuminate your room
Rubidium and Strontium than Ittrium, Zirconium
Niobium, Molybdenum, Technetium
Ruthenium, Rhodium, Palladium
Silver-ware then Cadmium and Indium
Tin cans, Antimony than Tellurium and Iodine and Xenon and then Sesium and ...
Barium is 56 and that is where the table separates
Where lanthanides just started
Lantern, Serium and Praseodimium
Neodimium is on the side
Promethium, then 62th
Samarium, Europium, Gadolinium and Terbium
Disprosium, Holmium, Erbium, Tulium
Itterbium, Lutetium
Hafnium, Tantalum, Tungsten then we come to ...
Rhenium, Osmium and Iridium
Platinum, Gold to make you rich until you're old
Mercury to tell you if it's very cold
Tallium and Lead then Bismuth vit your stomach
Polonium, A states will not taste good
Radon, Fransium will only stay for a little while
Radium then actinide at 89
This is the Periodic Table
Precious gases are stable
Halogens and alkali react aggressively
Every period will see a new outside shell
while electrons are moving to the right
Aktinium, Torium, Proktinium
Uranium, Neptune, Plutonium
Amerikium, Kurium, Berkelium
Californium, Einsteinium, Fermium
Mendelevium, Nobelium, Lawrencium
Rutherfordium, Dubnium, Seaborgium
Bohrium, Hassium then Meitnerium
Darmstadtium, Roetgenium, Copergenium
Nihonium, polyvinyl
Moscovium, Livermorium
Tennessine, Organesson
and
Dan
Are we
FINISHED!!!
Thanks to everyone for watching! If you liked the song make sure to check it out on iTunes and Bandcamp, put the link below.
If you think you'll enjoy other video material like this, be sure to subscribe to our channel.
And we'll put some of our most up-to-date video footage in there, so go and see!
You can also check out at ASAPscience.com to keep up with everything!
Otherwise we'll see you next time! Peace!